What if I told you I knew a way to dodge taxes
on a chunk of your paycheck? Or how about
an investment opportunity that will never
pay a penny of taxes on the growth no matter
how big it gets? Sound too good to be true?
No, we’re not talking about some off-shore
account in the Cayman islands. This is the
amazing tax shelter of the IRA - a government-created
program designed to incentivize you to save
more for your future self.
In 1974, Congress wanted a way to incentivize
the country to start saving for their own
retirement, and rely less on government programs
or company pensions. Their result was the
creation of the first IRA.
The “I” stands for “Individual”, meaning
you don’t get to co-own an IRA with someone
else, and it’s not dependent on a company
offering it to you, like a 401(k). The “R”
stands for retirement, meaning you promise
not to withdraw the money until you reach
a certain age. And the “A” can either
mean “account” or “arrangement” according
to the IRS. Contrary to popular belief, an
IRA isn’t an “investment” itself with
a set interest rate or statistics. It’s
a holding cell for your investment of choice.
An Individual Retirement “Account” can
be set up at nearly any bank or investment
company, and can hold investments like mutual
funds, stocks or ETFs. But an IRA doesn’t
have be an “account”. “Individual Retirement
Arrangements” allow you to apply the same
tax-benefits to an investment like a piece
of land or a small business. Some folks have
even used this “arrangement” to tax-shelter
dairy cows, a car wash and a habanero pepper
farm! As long as you play by the rules, you
can get pretty creative about what you choose
to invest in.
IRA’s can be broken down to two primary
styles; “Traditional” and “Roth”.
The Traditional IRA is the O.G. IRA. When
you’re going “Traditional”, you’re
allowed to save up to $6,000 dollars a year,
or $7,000 dollars if you’re over age 50.
And as long as you meet the criteria, any
money you save into a Traditional IRA is tax-deductible.
Translation: The more you save, the less taxes
you’ll owe this year!
And since you’re paying less taxes, you
have more money to…potentially invest in
your IRA! Essentially, it helps you boost
up the amount you save every year. As the
years go by and your account grows, you don’t
have to report the growth on your taxes. But
when retirement arrives and it’s time to
pull to the money out, the amount you withdraw
gets taxed as ordinary income.
If you’re a freelancer or own a small business,
you qualify for some special variations of
the Traditional IRA; the first is the SEP
IRA. SEP stands for Simplified Employee Pension,
and can be ideal for self-employed people.
The SEP will allow you to raise your $6,000
dollar funding limit to the lesser of $56,000
dollars or 25% of your compensation. That’s
a HUGE potential tax deduction each year!
But beware, if you have any employees, you’ll
probably have to fund their IRA’s at the
same rate as your own.
And if you work for or own a small business,
the SIMPLE IRA is kind of like a Traditional
IRA blended with a 401(k). Available to companies
with 100 employees or less, the $6,000 dollar
funding limit is raised to $13,000 dollars
and offers a saving-match incentive to workers,
usually a 3% matching contribution. So whether
you own or work for the small business, the
SEP and SIMPLE can help you level up a basic
Traditional IRA
Then there’s the Roth IRA, the cooler, younger
brother of the Traditional IRA. Making its
debut in the 1990’s, and named after Senator
Bill Roth, the Roth IRA flips the tax benefit.
Instead of getting a tax deduction on the
income you put in now, the capital gains,
interest, and growth can be withdrawn tax-free
in your golden years — with no limit! This
is super attractive to younger investors,
since their investments can rack up so much
compound-growth over their lifetime, there’s
a potential boatload of taxes they can avoid.
Let’s say you started maxing out your Roth
IRA at $6,000 dollars a year every year starting
at age 25. And let’s imagine that money
gets invested in index funds that grow at
average rate of 8% per year. If you did just
that until you reached 65, you’d have around
$1.67 Million dollars.
Under ordinary circumstances, whenever you
profit from an investment, you need to pay
taxes. But thanks to your “arrangement”
with the government, your Roth IRA hooks you
up big time. In our simplified example, your
“gains” account for $1.43 of your $1.67
million dollars. And assuming you owed a “15%
capital gains tax” on those gains, you’d
normally be on the hook for over $214,000
dollars in taxes. But thanks to the Roth,
that number is $0!
A couple important things to keep in mind
when investing through an IRA. First, you
can’t touch the money until age 59 ½, or
you’ll with get hit with taxes AND a 10%
early withdrawal penalty. Though there are
a few exceptions to this rule, like paying
for college or buying a home. And contributions
or deductions might be limited or eliminated
if you and/or your spouse aren’t working
or have a 401(k) or other retirement plan
through your job. And even non-working spouses
can save into their IRA if they choose.
So which IRA is right for you? Luckily, you
don’t have to limit yourself to only one
- many people have multiple IRAs—as long
as the total investment doesn’t exceed your
yearly cap. The factors that might make a
Roth, Traditional, SEP or SIMPLE IRA a good
fit are unique to you - your age, your income,
your goals.
Speaking with a tax professional and a financial
planner about your situation will always be
a safe bet when deciding which IRA to house
your investments of choice. They can help
you make sure you play by all the rules of
the “arrangement” and don’t overlook
anything.
But one thing’s for sure - the advantages
of saving into an IRA early and often are
truly too good to pass up.
And that’s our two cents!
Thanks to our patrons for keeping Two Cents financially healthy.
Click the link in the description if you'd like to support us on Patreon.
Do you have any other questions about how IRA's work?
Ask us in the comments.